I mean just thinking about that damn
like wow what a horrible day hi my name
is Donna I am a sous chef at a luxury
hotel restaurant and I've been doing
this for eight years now hi my name is
Yoli I'm a chef de cuisine and I've been
working in this industry for about 15
years so I was working at a it was a
Michelin star restaurant so already go
in there and you're very we feel a lot
of pressure very stressed out I was
trying to finish all my prep before
dinner service started and you're on
you're by yourself in your own station
so you have a lot of stuff to do and a
limited amount of time and you can do
not have time to mess anything up so I
believe I was slicing lemons very thinly
sliced lemons when I just got a little
bit distracted and I sliced a piece of
my finger off it was a good size I would
say it was like the tip of it maybe like
the size of the top of the fingertip I
was able to see some of the actual meat
in my finger it didn't hurt because the
blade was just very sharp plus the
initial shock of a piece of your finger
being on the table I was very upset
because I had to throw away my prep
clean everything is just like a waste of
time but then I was trying to think of
how I can salvage some time and that
part of my finger that was on the ground
well on the table and I needed to figure
all of this out very quickly because I
didn't want to waste any more time I
picked up the little piece of finger
that was on the table and I just tried
to stop the bleeding I put some spray
that coagulates your blood and it
stopped it pretty quickly I didn't want
to lose that piece of finger it was very
important to me so I figured hey we use
this thing it's like meat glue that we
use here where we roll some stuff and
bacon throw
little bit of meat glue and it like
seals perfectly so I made of meat so I
decided to sprinkle the meat glue on my
finger and just pretend like nothing
ever happened
put a big old bandaid on a glove and I
changed it throughout service and I
didn't tell anybody because I didn't
want anyone to send me home I just it's
a very stressful situation when you're
under pressure like that so I worked the
entire service while I was bleeding
while I was trying to glue a piece of my
finger back together when I went home it
looked very gross but I I kept
sprinkling that glue on my finger and
amazingly it worked it glued together
which is weird and I know it's
unbelievable but it worked it healed I'm
a huge advocate for meat glue now dine
la it is the worst thing that we need to
go through especially when your chef is
very ambitious and wants to have a full
menu going and a sample menu and so
we're really busy and it's the second
night of service and I'm on pasta for
the first time and I'm trying to make a
farro which is for a farro risotto dish
and I make it there's like an hour left
before service starts and I try it and
immediately all I taste is salt and so
I'm like what who touched my risotto so
I'm freaking out but I don't have time
for it because we have like 200 on the
books to start so I throw it away and I
started again like hoping that the chef
doesn't notice that it's not ready yet
and I make it and I'm done and I try it
again and I didn't put any salt in it
and again I'm like what is going on this
just tastes like pure salt so now I have
no time and I'm like rushing I'm hoping
that no one gets that order until I
finish it again but I'm like let me try
everything and so I try it all separate
and then I realized that the veg stock
was actually not labeled it was like an
old sticker on it and it wasn't veg
stock it was chicken brine which if you
know that's like just pure liquid salt
so I was like god
and I start all over again and once I'm
done in my line is set up take it start
coming in all these modifications
because everyone is super cheap during
guy in LA trying to split everything but
it's true and so I get it like going I
have like a good rhythm with me and I
get a ticket that is no sauce no salt no
butter nothing just like flame noodles
and I'm like this is weird but whatever
so I do it and I finish it and right
when I'm about to plate it they tell me
to
they bring a dog bowl and I'm like
freaking rich people of course I'm
feeding your dog right now so I played
it I put it up five minutes later I see
the dog bowl coming back and I like the
dog loves my stuff probably gonna be
this dog's private chef one day and no I
actually have to remake its food all
over again because I insulted the dog by
putting it in a dog bowl so while I'm
trying to catch up with my tickets I
have to also remake this pasta or dog
and played it on our expensive plates so
that it could be an accurate
presentation I mean I think the dog was
a happy customer at the end of it it
doesn't really matter the other end of
it like who's Eating what or even if it
is a person at the end of it it just
enjoy making the food so it's always
worth it and it's just like test your
patience constantly so I was working at
a restaurant many years ago and it was
very busy and it was during die in LA
and dine la is already a nightmare
within itself from opening to when you
close it's nonstop people coming and
going so you have to work in the kitchen
like a while oiled machine
one minor step back can throw off
service and lag ticket times and we had
just a little minor bump in the road so
it's I would say it was about 8:30 or
9:00 right one it's like prime time
everyone who's like focused
and we're just in the back cooking
expediting and sending out the tickets
when a server comes back and he looks
very scared he also looks a little bit
wet and then another server comes back
who also looks scared and also looks a
little bit wet and then we find out that
somebody had put the big like heating
outdoor heating things and they put them
too close to a fire extinguisher thing
and it's sprayed the entire patio which
was about five or six tables we lost
about 20 dishes of food all of the
people that were sitting outside had to
be receded in the dining room we had to
remake the food for them while trying to
continue to make the food for the people
that were not affected by it it it was
very stressful I would have cried but I
was just it was it was it was an
accomplishment and we were all really
happy at the end high-fiving each other
you know no one died of like stress or
panic so it was good so it is my first
time in a fine dining professional
kitchen and the chef is always on me
constantly like to better me always on
my ass basically and so he comes up to
me and it's like I'm gonna be on you
like white on rice all day and the
service you're gonna go feeling like a
badass but during the process I'm going
to break you and I'm like cool can't
wait but I had just gotten out of a
relationship not my choice but I had to
show up to work because you can't call
off and every time he came up to me I
was like don't cry don't cry and at the
end of it like I just started crying and
I ran out but can't escape a busy
kitchen so he finds me and he's like
you're gonna go back in there we're
gonna cut onions all of service
and that's what I had to do so I'm in
the back like a sad little puppies
chopping away pickled onions 25 pound
case I did feel like very empowered
after all of it but it was a lot of
tears my eyes were definitely burning
that experience and that night of
cutting 25 pounds of red onions molded
me into the thick-skinned person I am
and now I tell people all the time I'm
like you're gonna cry in this kitchen
you're gonna grab an onion and you're
gonna start slicing and gonna get some
thick skin
so I appreciate it at the end not at the
moment so even through all these
horrible events that happen in the
kitchen I still love what I do it's
definitely not for people who want a
nine-to-five like easygoing job like
every day you go into work and you're
like what is gonna happen today so you
have to love that sense of excitement
you do have to have a lot of passion and
I think I I do and all the chefs I've
worked for have been mentors sadistic
mentors for sure but they have like
molded me and I respect them all there's
a lot of sacrifices you sacrifice your
personal life family time you work every
weekend you have scars from burning but
at the end of the day if you this is
your passion then it's completely worth
it
[Music]
you
[Music]